The jogan Experience um what has it been
like uh you've you've owned X for a year
now oh
yeah do you do you ever wake up in the
middle of the night and have a dream
that you didn't do
it and your life is infinitely easier
well it's certainly
um a recipe for trouble I suppose
or contention um what was it ultimately
that led you to make the decision to do
it
I mean this is going to sound uh
somewhat melodramatic but I was worried
about that that it was having a
corrosive effect on
civilization uh that it was uh just
having a bad a bad impact um and
um I think part of it is that it's where
it's where it was located which is uh
you know downtown San Francisco um and
while I I think San Francisco is a
beautiful city and and we should really
fight hard to um kind of write the ship
of San Francisco if you've walked around
downtown San Francisco right near the
xfk Twitter headquarters it's a zombie
apocalypse I mean it's rough have you
have you been been in that area not
lately no I've heard it's crazy I've
heard it's crazy I've heard you you
really can't believe it until you
actually go there you can't believe it
until you go there so now you have to
say well what philosophy led to that
outcome and that philosophy was being
piped to
Earth so um you know a philosophy that
would be ordinarily quite Niche and
geographically constrained so that that
sort of the Fallout uh area would be
limited um was effectively given an
information a
weapon um a tech Information Technology
weapon to propagate
uh what is essentially a mind virus to
the rest of both um and the outcome of
that mind virus is very clear if you
walk around the streets of downtown San
Francisco it is the end of
civilization and it's not just uh
propagating the Mind virus but
suppressing any opposing
viewpoints yes well in order for the
virus to propagate it must suppress
opposing viewpoints so because it
doesn't stand up to scrutiny
correct yeah I mean you you I mean
you've you you you you've felt the the
virus yeah yeah people try to cancel you
so many times yeah it's fascinating yeah
um I don't think you're melodramatic at
all I I I think it's a it's a I mean I
don't want to be melodramatic but it's
almost like a death cult it's a death
cult no no that is exactly right um it
it's essentially the uh
extinctionist like it's in the limit it
is that they're propagating uh the
extinction of humanity and
civilization um and and there's some
people who are are like most most the
time it's it's implicit they don't but
sometimes it's explicit like there was a
guy on the front page of the New York
Times uh who literally has the thing
called the extinctionist movement um and
he was quoted on the front page of New
York Times as saying uh there are 8
billion people on the world but it would
be better if there were
none and I'm like well buddy you can
start with yourself yeah um does he have
friends that's what always fascinates me
well here he is he looks like you not
long for this
Earth I mean he doesn't voluntary human
extinction movement that's hilarious
spend I'd like to party with that dude I
would just like to like that's that's
that's that's the death that's that's an
explicit version of the death cult yeah
maybe long and die out it's I mean it's
it's
not Extinction is a word he uses yes no
I mean it's not a it's literally a
self-description
was in charge of social social media and
still largely is at uh Google and
Facebook by the way
yeah so I'm like uh I'm not in favor of
uh human extinction uh they are and uh
they can go to hell well that guy is
yeah he can go to hell that guy seems
silly I I would like to hang out with
him though I would like to find out what
makes him tick I bet that guy is
fascinating well you get him alone for a
few days I'm in favor of I me I'm Pro
environment but the the the in the limit
uh if you go if if you take
environmentalism to an extreme you start
to view Humanity as a plague on the
surface of the Earth like a like a mold
or something right um
and but it's this is actually false the
Earth could could take probably 10 times
the the current civilization the the
population could be you could 10x the
population without uh destroying the Rin
Forest so the the the the environmental
movement and and I'm an environmentalist
has gone too far they've gone way too
far um you know if you if you start
thinking that that humans are bad then
the natural conclusion is humans uh
should die out now I'm headed to an AI
safety International sort of AI safety
conference uh later tonight leaving in
about three hours um and um I meet with
the British prime minister a number of
other
people um so you have to say like how
could ai go wrong well if if if AI gets
programmed by the
extinctionist it will it's utility
function will be the extinction of
humanity so I mean there are times when
masks are warranted but most of the time
it's it's actually counterproductive
well that was one of the things about
the old Twitter was the propaganda and
yeah the adherence to whatever the CDC
was saying and the dism missing of
legitimate scientists guys like uh Jay
bachara from Stanford and legit guys yes
and they were suppressing them and even
Banning them they banned Alex baronson I
mean this is it was wild they banned
Alex for essentially reading
peer-reviewed papers yeah no I mean all
Twitter was basically an arm of the
government yeah so was that shocking
like what was that like cuz that to me
that was the most bizarre was the
Twitter files when you let shellburg and
Matt taibe and all those guys get in the
Twitter and the response were Matt taiii
gets audited I mean which is just wild I
mean it's just so blatant and so in your
face yeah it's weird no I
mean the yeah the the degree to which
and and by the way Jack didn't really
know know this but the degree to which
Twitter was simply um an arm of the
government was not well understood by
the public and and uh it it was there
was no it was whatever the official
government it was like prda basically um
you know a state publication is the way
to think of old Twitter it's a state
publication and was the justification
from their perspective that they are
progressive liberals they have the right
intentions it's important that they stay
in power the progressive liberals stay
in government and power because this is
the this is their there there was there
was uh basically oppression of of
um any any views that would even I would
say be considered middle of the road um
but certainly anything on the the right
I'm not talking about like like far
right I'm just talking mildly right the
people like Republicans were suppressed
at 10 times the rate of Democrats um now
that's because uh old Twitter was
fundamentally controlled by the
farle it was like completely controlled
by the the far-left
and that's why I say like the like San
Francisco Berkeley is a niche ideology
it's hard to say like is there a place
that's more far-left than San Francisco
Berkeley maybe Portland maybe Portland
but it's like it's a right there it's
those two places are the the most far
left places uh in America yes um so from
their standpoint everything is to the
right including moderates right right so
now if if if you internalize a left
position uh everything seems wrong to
you that if that is not far left right
and so they naturally oppressed any
anything that didn't agree with their
views that's why I say that it was an
accidental far-left information weapon
so
uh it because it's like Silicon Valley
attracts the smartest Engineers the
smartest sort of technologists and
programmers from around the world um
they created an information weapon that
was then harnessed by the farle who
could not themselves create the weapon
but happened to be collocated where the
technologists were and happened to be
aligned politically with the people that
possessed it the technologists are
generally are moderate maybe moderate
left but they're they're not they're
they're not farle that's why I say San
Francisco Bley it's it's it doesn't even
extend to South San Francisco or even to
paloalto so so SF Berkeley is the most
farle um perhaps you know in a
competition with Portland but I'd say SF
Bley is more farle even than
Portland like literally in America it's
we're talking about an area that's maybe
a 10 mile
radius and so the normally the the
effects the negative effects of a
far-left ideology that is would be
geographically limited to a 10 mile
radius that's like not it's small like
the so so any any bad effects of that
ideology would be geographically
constrained under normal circumstances
and have been in the past but when you
have uh basically a techn technological
megaphone which which was Twitter and
social media in general suddenly the the
farle are handed a megaphone to
Earth a an incredibly powerful
technology weapon that they themselves
could create but they happen to be
collocated with the technologists who
created
it by
accident is it shocking that more people
don't understand how dangerous that
is I think some people understand um
some people do some people understand um
so I mean from the standpoint of of some
of people who used to be a Twitter uh
the people like well it's a big shift to
the right that is correct it is a shift
to the right because every everything is
to the right if you're far left
everything is to the
right but it's but how many farle people
have actually been suspended or Bann
from from Twitter now X
zero so it's really just moved to the
center but from the perspective of the
far-left it is it's moved to the right
like Everything's
Relative
the the the difference in moderation
sorry I should say it's it propagated
that Fallout philos be not just to
America but to everywhere on earth right
yeah yeah and with the same level
suppression in other countries as well
yes but the Taliban is on
Twitter
right like I always think of like hey Mr
Taliban T your
banana hey Mr Talib I mean there but
there's definitely some people on
Twitter that are daylight coming I want
to go yeah
um yeah so the point the point is um I
that I from my standpoint uh that is
that X FK Twitter um should uh represent
the sort of collective consciousness of
humanity so now that that means that
there going to be views on there that
you don't like um or disagree with
um but that's
Humanity so are you going to exclude
them or or not now I mean if if somebody
you know breaks the law then then the
account is suspended I mean if they uh
ad actively Advocate murder then the
account is suspended we we do have what
call like the kind of United Nations
exclusion rule which is that you can
have say the
iolla who you know
uh would would prefer that Israel didn't
exist for example um and um but he's
allowed to go to the UN building in New
York um and uh in fact generally
officials from Iran uh do in fact go to
the UN building in New York um even
though they are heavily sanctioned
country so so I think that there's
there's Merit to
having uh just like there's mer there's
some Merit to the UN one can disagree
with the UN and I think one we shouldn't
have a world government that we bow down
to but in fact that's risky for
civilization but I think you do want to
have the leaders of countries uh
represented um on social
media